okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the electromagnetic spectrum I'm
going to introduce you to the concept of
the spectrum and we're going to have a
look at the seven different parts of the
electromagnetic spectrum okay so first
of all the electromagnetic spectrum is
just made up of transverse waves
now it's split into seven different
parts as you can see I've done a kind of
diagram of the waves and how they change
as we go from one side to the other side
now all of these waves all of them
transfer energy now we need to know the
names and the order of these different
waves these different parts so the first
type here
radio waves now once we've gone through
the seven parts we're going to have a
look at the actual differences between
them
the second batch are microwaves they
have a slightly shorter wavelength than
Micra than radio waves next up we have
infrared then visible light now visible
light this is the only part of the
electromagnetic spectrum that we can
actually see so our eyes can detect
these frequencies of of electromagnetic
of the electromagnetic spectrum we
cannot see any of these other waves this
is why it's called the visible light
section the spectrum this part here the
next part is ultraviolet then x-rays and
finally we have gamma rays now as you
can see it's a continuous spectrum that
is then separate and split into these
seven different categories these seven
different subsections so what's the
difference between the different
sections now basically you have the two
different ends of the spectrum with
radio waves at one end and gamma rays
all at the other
now as you can see here the radio waves
are the waves that have the longest
wavelength remember wavelength just
means the distance between the peak of
two waves like this so they have by far
the longest wavelength now as you go
further this way the wavelength gets
shorter and shorter between each wave so
each of these different subsections is
just the category based on the
wavelength so right at this end gamma
rays you can see these gamma rays have a
really short wavelength so that's how
they're kind of separated into these
different sections it's also we can have
a look at how frequency changes you go
from one side to the other the frequency
means how many waves pass a point per
second so on this side we actually have
the lowest frequency in terms of our
radio waves whereas over here the gamma
rays we have a really really high
frequencies this is where the frequency
is highest now basically the higher the
frequency of the wave the more energy
that it transfers so therefore it's more
dangerous so therefore we have this side
is described as being the most ionizing
so these waves because of their high
frequency they they transfer a lot of
energy so therefore they are more
dangerous than most ionizing in another
video describes what ionizing actually
means whereas these ones here are the
least ionizing due to their low
frequency now those are basically the
features that split up we then we then
based on wavelength they're separated
into these seven different sections now
a similarity between all of them however
is they all travel at the same speed
they all travel at 300
million meters per second so despite
having different wavelengths different
frequencies they all travel at the same
speed the speed of light 300 million
meters per second so visible light
travels at this speed in a vacuum radio
waves travel at this speed in a vacuum
and so does gamma rays relative speed in
a vacuum so those are similarities now
the final thing I want to say to
introduce you to the electromagnetic
spectrum it's just a nice little
mnemonic to help remember the order
remember we need to know the order that
they come in so the little mnemonic is
this red monsters invading us using
x-ray goggles so here's the little
monster help to help you remember it and
there's his x-ray goggles so radio waves
if there are so red for radio age M for
microwaves eye for infrared V for
visible light you for ultraviolet X for
x-rays and G for gamma rays so red
monsters invade rhiness using x-ray
goals is a helpful way to remember the
order of the electromagnetic spectrum
I've also made a video of each of these
different types of waves to find out
their uses and a little bit more
information about each one thank you